so before we talk about sexual desire
and anger it's important to note that
al-hazali has his own
compartmentalization of the like the
well or the operations of the pulp of
the heart oh hey we're talking about the
spiritual life and this anime is very
clear the difference between the pump
the physical art and the spiritual heart
and so for example he mentions that
there are three things or three
processes if you like or three classes
he refers to as which which kind of in
here in the cult number one is if you
like the carnal desires which include
sexual aggressive urges which are going
to come to you now but the other two are
the propensity for the human being to
enact to enact with power whatever it is
their will that they want to enact and
the third thing is he refers to as
basically the drak or the hawas or the
the five senses so this is his
compartmentalization now on the point of
sexual desire and urges in he doesn't
paint the picture necessarily that anger
and sexual desire are negative forces in
love themselves in fact they have a
function if you think about it and this
is how he represents it sexual desire is
a pulling force and anger is a pushing
force because when you when you're
sexually aroused by something or
somebody you want them whereas when
you're angry it's destructive you want
to hurt them or you want it away from
you you see so it's a pushing force
versus a pulling Force the appetites or
the the sexual desire and and the anger
now he puts forward a series of
interesting analogies I'll just mention
two here they're a full-time in brevity
and conciseness the verses of a city
actually uh and the city here where your
or your your rationality your intellect
your unemotional self all these things
are there represents the king and the
police the chief of police is anger
emblematic of justice disciplinarianism
and all those kind of things but the
chief of police is anger so he says that
you need to put anger into good use
basically but if there's corruption
let's call it for the sake of argument
with the police and then let the police
is trying to to revolt against the
leader then the leaders must you know
take charge of the situation
likewise he puts forth another very
interesting Parable he Compares sexual
desire to a pig because you know a pig
is not going to be held to account for
his sexual proclivities and its Its
Behavior we see how a pig acts as a
beastly animal that's why many people
say that men are pigs or many women
nowadays they may not picks because this
is the truth in that they can't control
their sexual desire men have sometimes a
a heightened intensity in not being able
to or weakness you could say and not
being able to control their Central
desire yeah and this is why this this
kind of criticism there's some truth in
it that men act like pigs sometimes and
this is that sexual desire represents
the pig and anger the dog he mentions is
like I will read this in fact from his
translated work it's become a PhD thesis
in fact translation of the first book of
the third quadrun he says that the dog
is anger for the carnivorous Beast and
the Savage dog are not the dog and the
Beast from the standpoint of their
appearance or color or shape but because
the spirit and meaning of this beastial
quality is savageness and enmity and
Slaughter now within man there is the
savageness and anger of the Beast and
the greed and voluptuousness of the pig
thus the pig through gluttony invites
man to excess and Abomination and the
wild beast by means of anger calls him
to oppress and the oppression and
harmful acts the demon continues to
serve up the appetite of the pig and the
Wrath of the wild beast or to incite one
by means of the other and and he makes
their inborn dispositions to appear good
to them the sage who represents the
intellect is in Duty bound to ward off
the plotting and guile of the demon by
revealing his dissembling by means of
his I.E the same is penetrating inside
and evident clear illuminations and to
destroy the gluttony of the pig by
setting the dog over him for by means of
anger he breaks down the assault of
appetense absence he rewards off the
savageness of the dog by setting the pig
over him and bringing the dog in
subjection under his rule if he does
this successfully
his Affairs are set right Equity is
Manifest in the Kingdom of the body and
all goes in the straight path what is
saying here is you need to be angry and
he mentions this in another book
actually
all the uh the book of self-examination
vigilance
he mentions why are we not angry we are
angry when people you know don't meet
our expectations you see but we're not
angry when we ourselves don't meet our
own expectations makes this point oh we
don't meet the expectations of God
you may feel guilty but are you angry
and this is the point we need to stop
being angry with our own selves our own
shortcomings so anger needs to be
redirected and this is why the sexual
aggressive desires Freud mentions these
couples them together many
psychoanalysis in the 20th century they
mentioned these two together are
inextricably Linked In this way if you
are able to somehow get an
instrumentalized and weaponize anger
against sexual desire then that is one
step closer to achieving Mastery and he
says but if he is unable to overcome
them they overcome him and bring him
into servitude and so he continues to
search out crafty tricks and careful
plans to satisfy his pick and please his
dog thus he is constantly in servitude
to a pig or a dog this is the condition
of the majority of mankind whenever
their primary concern is of the belly
sexual Indulgence vying With the Enemy
the strange thing is that he does proofs
of idolators worshiping Stones whereas
if the veil were removed and his true
state were disclosed and his true
condition set before him as it set
before mrxiani the the top guys in his
eyes either in his sleep or whom when
awake he would see himself stand before
a pig now prostrating himself before him
and again kneeling awaiting his signal
and his command so whenever the pig is
roused up to seek the satisfying of any
of his appetites the man is sent forth
at once to serve him and bring that for
which he lusts and the same thing he
mentions about the dog can't mention all
that now and this is a very powerful
image here that is either you that's
going to put the dog and the pig to
service for yourself or you are going to
figuratively of course prostrate to the
dog and the pig
the issue of anger is one that the Quran
and the Hadith and the Companions and
the predecessors all deal with
like for instance in the Quran where it
mentions that a very famous verse a very
important one of this issue which is
that
the ones who are able
to con suppress actually calvamine
Calhoun is suppression Calvin mean alive
the ones who are able to suppress their
anger and pardon the people now you'll
find that this kind of connection
between suppressing one's anger and
pardoning the people is kind of a line
of reasoning which runs through the
Quran for instance
that when they get angry they forgive
why because anger is a very volatile
emotion it's within the intuitive
interests the carnal bestial Savage
interest of the individual at that time
the brutish interest yes to go ahead and
inflict costs and harm
on an individual the object of anger
so what the Quran proposes here is that
if the high level people because it's
referring to the mussinin the high level
people the top Believers are the ones
who are able to control one of the most
volatile human emotions which is anger
yes at that time they do the
counter-intuitive thing where they want
to at that time exact anger in an
individual they do the opposite thing
exactly
now this is Apex spirituality this is
the top level thing you can imagine so
look what I have it deals with the
matter and the prophet Muhammad
he gave us many different
advices but one of them is really
interesting I mean when he's mentioning
the True Believers is
that actually the
strong one is not the one who can
wrestle well but the strong one is the
one who can control himself at the times
of anger meaning what true strength is
that is self-control because in reality
self-control
and mental resilience is a prerequisite
for any physical Endeavor not the vice
versa you need to have mental resilience
and self-control if you were to engage
in any sport or physical activity but
you don't need a physical ability to
engage in the mental self grappling if
you like so it's a prerequisite if you
are able to control your anger then for
those who are engaging in all kinds of
sports this actually will help you in
sports as the saying goes when they go
and gets tough the tough gets going but
for that to happen you need to get tough
and the prophet Muhammad is telling us
of means to nourish and develop this
mental resilience
yes
and the prophet gives us many practical
pieces of advice for example don't get
angry and if you're standing and sit if
you're sitting then lay down like change
distract yourself really and El fazali
has a very interesting we've spoken
about some of his analogies in another
video he has an entire chapter dedicate
it to anger in
that the book of the dispraise of anger
and and there's more resentment and has
had this Envy a whole chapter dealing
with the matter
and he starts off by talking about anger
as like a flick of fire which afflicts
the lowest part of the heart it's like
rubbing of iron against Stone he
mentions yes and then of course he
mentions all the Hadith that we've
mentioned as well the main thing that
he's mentioning here is that anger is
the enemy of intellect but not all anger
is bad and we've mentioned this before
and I'll mention it again a surefie
mentions that someone who doesn't get
angry at all is like a donkey he said
that uh
whoever is made to be angry and doesn't
get angry is like a is like a hermr it's
a donkey because if you see a donkey
yeah you'll realize that whatever you do
with a donkey doesn't care it's
indifferent apathetic human beings are
not meant to be like that actually
that's not a natural way of being if you
see injustices in front of you if you
see wrong things happening how are you
going to discipline your children if you
don't get angry there needs to be a
level of anger that they see in you so
that they can fix their behavior anger
is a healthy thing but it has to be in
moderation which is why he actually
breaks it down to classification he says
you've got three different kinds of
people and people that don't get angry
at all of course that's not praiseworthy
people that get angry all the time which
is of course is not praiseworthy at all
because that is in many ways can be
worse sometimes than the first category
and then the second character is the
media the Goldilocks zone the happy
medium which is that you get angry
sometimes but you're able to control
yourself and don't let it
obscure your rationality yes and then he
goes into a discussion which is very
interesting about why people get he says
that it's the removal of something for
example it could be the removal of
absolute Necessities I mean you for
example food a drink if you're hungry
and you need to eat someone tries to
take your food away you're you're gonna
get angry and this is happens in the
animal kingdom it happens with human
beings it's a natural thing and of
course there's a limit to that but we're
saying with also he mentions it could be
that you take something away that makes
something convenient for someone example
a servant or something like that you
have a servant or a maid or a butler and
then it's been taken away from you
something which in age of convenience
today the age of technology and
convenience something which we need to
know or he mentions that it could be
something that you deem to be important
like for example of books people who
like to read to have books that they
consider sentimental or very important
to them if that's to be taken away the
person gets angry and he says that the
way of dealing with those kinds of
things is to to be a minimalist
basically to imagine yourself going on a
journey and what will be the minimum
thing that you would require that in
reality these things are Superfluous you
don't actually need those things you
don't need those things be a minimalist
and the more minimalistic you are in
your reasoning the more you are able to
control your anger if certain things
happen to you and so this is one thing
and then he mentions the reason why
people don't get angry or able to
control their anger he says those
individuals who distract their minds
with other things for example for the
Muslim it will be something like tahit
itself
you can distract yourself with thinking
about Allah's attributes thinking about
Allah's names and attributes things
about this you can you can distract
yourself with that and knowing that
Allah does not like love anger he used
to be angry and out of control and so
when he talks about the Cure of anger
it's very interesting he talks about
you've got to explore the root cause and
he said there could be many root cause
he mentions he enumerates many root
causes if you think about it
psychoanalytically yes it could be
self-conceived yeah it could be deluded
it could be self-praise you think that
why deserve this how could this be taken
with him right could be Pride you're
arrogant and therefore how could he say
this to me how can you do this to me my
zillionus which is the idea of like you
know I'm not gonna give this guy my
money ridicule like you you enjoy it to
really put people down once again that
could be connected to Pride that you're
just someone who's addicted to
argumentation or could be great that
give me this now I want this and he
basically proposes the following he says
that for each of those sins The Cure of
it is the opposite so let me give you an
easy example miserliness if you feel
yourself finding it difficult to give
money then give charity give even more
charity and the same things like for
example self-praise you have to start
becoming more distance and so on another
thing is he mentions is that you've got
to think about the color of Allah the
the we've got to think about the fact
that what everything is written so
everything is meant to be if you really
believe in that then you'll be okay and
so these are some of the examples and
some of the points that he makes Allah
so this session what I'm going to be
doing is really advising Myself by
summarizing some of the things that I've
read I'm going to be talking about
things that I haven't been able to
master or even achieve unfortunately
things like humility things like that
which I'm trying to work on and this is
not me being again
artificially uh humble I'm not this is
not one of my character traits with the
Ishmael consensus of people who know me
so I'm not just saying this having said
that this particular Hadith of the
Prophet Muhammad sallam really stuck in
my mind
and I want to remind myself of it it's a
hadith's way of arrogance in his heart
will not enter Jannah then somebody came
from the companion senses
that surely you know a person loves a
man likes to wear beautiful clothes and
beautiful shoes
sadly Allah is beautiful and he loves
Beauty but then he defined for us and is
very important what Kiba is what is
arrogance he says arrogance means
rejecting the truth and belittling the
people now this is very important
actually has an entire uh chapter of
this which I'm just reading some of the
notes of we're trying to summarize them
to myself and this is essentially been
translated they've translated it a book
called all the condemnation of Pride
which can be purchased very good some of
the references is a bit difficult but
having said that first of all you know
you mentioned some of the hadees
condemning pride and arrogance the ones
I've just mentioned another one which I
found really interesting and very
powerful actually when one considers
another Hadith I just want to share with
you guys is the Hadith of the Prophet
Muhammad
where Allah and Allah saying honor is
my cloak this is obviously expressive
expressive here whoever buys with me
regarding one of them shall be tormented
do you know because
Allah it's not arrogance for Allah it's
granddaughter for us it's arrogance so
if you try and you know self-aggrandize
you're vying with Allah with that which
belongs to him this is a very powerful
thing which reminds us of subhanallah
our insignificance
actually makes some really interesting
distinction in his book and he
differentiates between elkebar and the
way he does so is very interesting he
says akibar the kibber which is
arrogance
it requires an object like for example
if you are alone in a in a desert island
and you were self-praising and looking
into the water and thinking wow I'm such
a great person this would be not Kibler
because kibble requires an object to be
done to okay so after kind of
distinguishing between one of the or one
of the other he mentioned seven major
reasons you see four kibber for
arrogance why does somebody become
why does somebody become arrogant and
one of those reasons is well let's let's
go through them so one of them is
attributional uh is for example you can
say it's a knowledge a person has
knowledge he thinks because he's learned
a few things that he can start putting
people down and we see this in the
culture of students of knowledge and
machine that they're all attacking each
other it's a very horrible scene out
there attacking each other's knowledge
or he's not on this level and he hasn't
even read that book and we also see it
in in different different Industries on
YouTube and in other places or this
person's not qualified this person is
not that sometimes people are not
qualified some people are problematic
individuals however if you think you're
better than somebody because you have
been given some knowledge that they have
not been given intrinsically this is
arrogance if you think you're better and
this is an important distinction if you
think you're better if this increases
your intrinsic worth and this is me
advising myself number two he says
actions and these can be obviously
religious actions for religious people
but other kinds of actions I've done
this and I've done that why do this and
I do that and this person doesn't do
this and doesn't do that so then someone
can start becoming arrogant because of
it another reason he brings forth is
lineage I come from this family we're
from this clan and arrogance can come
about because of that and like asali has
some very interesting you know kind of
analogies here where he's talking about
the fact that this is the case you know
oh a bacteria or worms which reside in
the body of an animal versus a human
being is the same thing but it's you
know he he talks about the fact that it
does you are not responsible for where
you came from just as the worm or or a
bacteria is not responsible for where
it's you know inhab what it's inhabiting
so why would you try and Glory hunt
which many people do now football soccer
culture for something which you yourself
have not achieved and he mentions also
Beauty which is of course can be for men
and can be for women
I mean we'll say look at how he looks
and how look at her she looks how she's
done this to herself and she doesn't
know that and look how big of a fat she
is and because of that or how skinny she
is and look at her small her breasts are
and women do this to each other men do
this to each other with how his biceps
are this his legs are small or look how
short he is and these are some things
are completely out of your control
anyway and and what gazelle wants us to
remember here is that actually your
beauty or what you think is beauty is
going to wither and the same thing he
mentioned which is another reason is
strength strength is going to decline
your strength is going to decline so oh
you know this guy's weak I can finish
him whatever it's very much there
another thing which is he mentions a
reason for he'll get angry is money or
I've made this about how much money do
you make bro like what you make this
much money but people now compete on
this and in the Quran has this ayat on
this one
they try and pile up money and they
think that money makes them rich
makes them a better person an
intrinsically better person like someone
Rich doesn't make them Rich makes them a
you know a better person so a lot you
know the al-hazali is reminding us it's
not the case and clearly in the Quran
that's not the case
for example mentions that he thinks his
money is going to make him Immortal to
become self-denuted because of it so
these are some of the things and he says
that there are some fundamental causes
of of Pride and kibber and he he Narrows
them down into four he says look you've
got one of them which is internal and
three of them which is external the
internal one is itself which we talked
about so a loud job which is
self-amazement
can lead to arrogance because you think
well look how amazing I am all these
guys are not as amazing as I am the
moment you connect it with an object
another object outside of yourself it
can become arrogance uh and so he also
mentions some other external things
pretension and pretension is basically
you're just speaking and pretending to
know what you're talking about so that
you can be seen as higher up in reality
you're not you're not that guy like for
example when a child debates with more
intelligent parent you're being
pretentious here because you know that
that parent is more intelligent than you
but you're just doing that because you
want to
show that you're you're clever as well
or something like that another reason is
resentment
you know you might resent somebody so
you think you know what this person's
not and this is satanic luciferian this
person I don't like him therefore I'm
better than them you know it comes quite
easily It comes naturally Envy is the
same thing because what is envy you want
that person to lose their blessing so if
you're envious of something someone that
you're more likely to to to start being
a multicabber towards them as well and
so what he does in terms of now with the
wanted treatment for these problems
because we've spoken here about some of
the problem or the treatment for some of
these problems and basically he says
look you need to it's the whole issue is
one of ignorance versus knowledge and he
has a long discussion on the issue but
basically he says that you need to know
that you you are not as you think you
are you are not as you think you are you
don't you you are self-deluded into
thinking that your wealth has made you
better or higher value or this or that
when you realize that you're gonna die
that 100 years from now you're not even
going to be mentioned that you're going
to be under the ground yeah that people
are not even gonna bear to be near your
dead corpse because of how the stenger
that certain Corps people are going to
actively want to forget you can you
imagine this when you remember these
things then
or you acknowledge that you are you are
a temporal existence in this transient
space called the Dunya when you have
proper knowledge of that then you don't
really have a reason to be able to keep
it at all
you know we are living in a culture
nowadays which basically people don't
want to take accountability take stock
of their own action and this destroys
relationships it destroys communities
destroys societies but in our tradition
the Islamic tradition the idea of
self-accountability was certainly one
which was emphasized pretty deeply and
in fact so much so that he's got an
entire book on the MATA in his magnum
opus his company's
workin the masterpiece
and the qatab is called the book of
essentially been translated into English
which is the book of self-examination
and vigilance I'm going to be looking at
the some of the notes I've I've taken
and tell you some of the things that he
has said
in regards to self-examination of course
first of all I mean there are many
acquired of the hanama and speeches of
the predecessors which are very
pertinent to this particular inquiry or
the subject of inquiry Chief Moss I
would say of the predecessors is what
ahmedab has said which is that
with that hold yourselves to account
before you are held to account what I
found very interesting about the book
um about this particular book is that he
starts off by putting forward a trade
analogy and he does this throughout his
book he makes analogies for states of
mind and psycho spiritual States so to
read some of it he says know that when
those who engage in Commerce and deal in
Commodities settle accounts they seek a
healthy profit hence the trader avails
himself of his associates handing him
his money for the trade and then
settling his account with him it's the
same with the intellect happen as it
does commerce on the way to the
Hereafter its object and profit is the
purification of the Soul because its
Felicity is through this Felicity it's
basically good fortune or it's success
it's very interesting how he phrases
that because actually he's what he's
saying to us is we should think of
purification self-examination in the
same way as we would think about
business we should want to make the
biggest profit possible and of course
making the biggest profit possible is
not just getting new business which in
this case would be doing good deeds but
it's also making sure that the customers
remain that we don't lose capital or
that we don't lose investment value that
of course means purifying ourselves and
and the way he mentions this is very
powerful he considers the heart as the
main organ it's the main organ and there
are seven members that lead to the heart
and which need to be purified and he
mentions that then the servant of God's
counsel to his soul about the moments of
his life after which he prefers counsel
about his seven members and what are the
other seven members the eye ear tongue
stomach the private parts hands and foot
these are the seven members in other
words one needs to keep track of what he
is seeing what he is hearing what he is
saying especially saying and he's got an
entire book on this in fact about how
your words can get you in trouble and
the many hadiths on the Mata you know
the other Jannah ER the prophet saws
said that I guarantee Jannah meaning
that Allah guarantees it for those who
are able to guarantee that which is
between their two legs and their two and
the jaw basically so this is and then he
goes into detail about all of those
seven things by holding yourself to
account for those seven things and so he
breaks it down into different
um if you like categories the first
thing is you have to make a commitment
to yourself you have to condition this
is called you condition I am not going
to do these things I am not going to you
say to yourself speak bad words swear
words I'm not going to swear you know I
am not going to back bite this person I
am not going to say and what is
backbiting is
saying that about your brother which she
hates all your sister of course do not
say that which your brother Muslim
brother or sister will not like it's a
form of cowardice don't do this yes well
I am not going to see something which is
Haram of course it's difficult to do
nowadays in the age that we're living in
but we have to do much we have to
condition ourselves for these kinds of
things and once you have done that once
you've conditioned yourself then you
start to examine yourself so this is the
stage two which he mentions you know
after you said to yourself look I'm not
going to do this and everyone's going to
fall into and this goes back to anefs
the Quran says that he swears
swear by the self reproaching Soul
meaning you keep exams so important that
Allah actually even makes which means he
he swears by it the reproaching so you
keep going back to Wi-Fi done that
regretting now in modern culture people
so you shouldn't agree anything I say
you shouldn't regret anything except for
your sins and I see this is exactly how
Islam you must regret your sins as a
part of nedem it's a part of October Ned
them as part of Toba regretting is part
of Tober so after you've done the
moshata then you have to we steadfast
now you try your best to stay on the
path that you're on and then you do
muhasaba watch your self-examination
after the ACT you do something bad you
examine yourself now if you think why
did this happen just as you would in any
situation like something happens you get
into a big argument with your spouse you
say something bad to your parents you
commit a major sin you commit a minor
sin you look where you shouldn't be
looking then you sit with yourself after
you've committed this sin which we were
all bound to commit and you say to
yourself that you know I why did I do
this what triggered this Behavior why
did I fall into this how can I make sure
that I don't go into this again so this
is another thing you do after you've
done that and you go on to the next
stage which he mentions and this is guys
this is extremely important let's be
honest because he mentions here look the
fact is and this is in this fifth
chapter and this is translated you can
read it yourself in fact is when a
person examines his soul he finds
tempted he finds it tempted by sin
therefore he must punish it in manners
described he mentioned it before you
have to discipline yourself
you don't just Discipline Your Child
you're not discipline this one or that
or you discipline yourself as well how
are you going to discipline yourself you
can fast you can do this you can you can
do Mana you can stop yourself from
having certain things if you don't
discipline yourself life will discipline
you you see and so that is uh the next
step and then this is a very powerful in
the sixth chapter this is he saw that I
say know that you you that your worst
enemy is your soul inside you it was
created to incite Ill and predisposed
towards evil and desecration of the good
so this once again it's a very
interesting take and he starts going
into a monologue and hazal he's got this
very powerful way of just telling it how
it is listen to what he says here he
says oh so if a servant of yours nay a
brother should confront you with
something you dislike what anger and
Loathing would you Harbor for him yet
how recklessly you then expose yourself
to God's loathing anger and Stern
punishment do you think you can bear his
wrath far from it if your Cockiness has
lulled you away from his painful wrath
then try for yourself put yourself under
the sun or in the bath house for an hour
bring your fingers close to the flame
and find out how you better or are you
deluded about God's nobility and favor
his disinterested Miss with respect to
your acts of obedience and worship why
do you not rely on his kindness and the
weighty matters of the world when a foe
pursues you why'd you just devise a
stratagem to repel him without relying
on God's kindness you see we are
self-deluded and he has a very powerful
monologue book is filled with these
kinds of monologues one should have a
systemized method of holding themselves
to account and with that I conclude
assalamual
the issue of Envy is of particular
significance today in the age of
comparison yeah social media has made
the world like a global village
you've got Instagram you've got YouTube
you've got all these kinds of Facebook
whatever it may be and people are just
kind of comparing one another with one
another
and as such Envy creeps into the heart
and it creates great discomfort and
inconvenience uh I think we should start
here by talking about the main a Hadith
that relate to hasid of course we all
know the verse in the Quran
um
that we seek Refuge from and one of the
things that we seek Refuge from
is the Envy of the envious person when
they Envy but there is a that's more of
a protective measure you see in the
Hadith which is also in the 40 Hadith
we have a very interesting and very
powerful Hadith which is starts actually
the prophet saws
you know do not envy one another and
there's all kinds of things that
continue saying you know do not inflate
prices over one another does not hate
one another do not turn away from one
another do not undercut one another and
trade however instead Muslim
yeah that instead be you know the you
know Brothers in faith and a Muslim is a
brother of another Muslim he does not
oppress him nor does he fail him nor
does he lie to him nor does he hold him
in contempt and then he pointed to his
hearts of Allah
is
God Consciousness or piety is in in the
heart and so this is the first thing you
know and another Hadith which is I think
as important maybe is whether Prophet
sallam told us once again
you know that be aware of Envy because
Envy consumes the virtues just as fire
consumes the firewood
in his book and this one his uh his book
of basically
sorry of envy that the way you've got to
conceived of this is that God gives
gifts to people you see
so to Envy somebody is to express this
pleasure with the distribution of God
now I want you to think about this for a
second
if your issue with someone is that they
have something you don't have you wish
you had it
and we're going to talk about the levels
of NV here but if you you have this in
your heart why did they have a not me if
this question pops into your mind if you
if you're a female you're thinking about
someone else who has you know another
woman for example who has certain things
that you don't have a certain life that
you don't have certain house that she
lives in that you don't have because
these are the kind of thing or if you're
a man that you may be thinking once
again the man this this guy's making
more money than I am he's driving a
different car that I to me he's got
better status or worldly status and of
course religious people will tend to to
be jealous over religious matter so this
person is more knowledgeable than I am
and we'll come to this as well whatever
it is that comes into your heart this is
problematic because it expresses a
displeasure with the distribution of God
of course we've got the famous story of
Surat Yusuf in the Quran which kind of
exemplifies this point
um and however there is one thing which
is important I should mention which is
that the Hadith or the prophet Muhammad
who said you know
that there is no I feel like envy that
is Justified except for in two types of
thing which is the prophet a man who
Allah has given knowledge of the Quran
and so he recites it during the night
and the day and the man who Allah has
given wealth so he spends from it during
the day and the night what kind of Envy
is allowed here in scholar sales engines
as well it's the kind of in so-called
envy and this is envy and kind of
quotation marks here
it's the kind of Envy where you don't
wish that the other person lost their
blessing and so there are three stages
of envy that Allah mentions the first
one is that you love something for
example wealth and wish that that person
didn't have it now this is a blameworthy
type of asset which there is nothing in
the religion of Islam or in fact that
justifies generally speaking having this
kind of an emotion towards someone else
and you can and he'll tell us how if you
have this and we have to be honest about
it expunge yourself of such a feeling
the second is that you wish to have
something that someone else had but you
don't wish for them to lose that
blessing now this is lawful but it's not
commendable
So you you're still kind of thinking
because there is a there's an aspect of
okay well I'm not happy with what I have
have there's an actor aspect of lack of
contentment here going on
it's so this is important and the third
one is to wish someone sorry to wish
that you have what someone else has on
religious matters like the Hadith
mentions you see for example more
knowledge of the Quran uh more money so
they can give it in charity and these
kinds of things now there are seven
causes he mentions mentions
of Hazard of NV the first one is enmity
that you you feel like oh this guy's my
enemy and therefore I wish that whatever
he had didn't have it so anything that
happens is good to that person you know
you're actually you you get disappointed
there's a feeling of your heart your
heart
um gets hard maybe you know or it drops
your heart your heart drops when
something good happens to someone else
that you dislike I didn't want that to
happen do you mean you didn't want that
to happen why because you don't like
that person and this is something which
is not allowed in the Sharia
the second one is dislike for another's
good
diani for example if someone else
someone's got something good and you
think like you know what I don't want
that person to have that
but it's not because you necessarily
hate them but it is what it is the third
thing is private
so you hold a certain person in contempt
however having said that modern
psychologists differentiate between
arrogance and contempt and we're not
going to go into the distinction
although suffice it for me to say this
juncture that contempt by modern
standards is where there's equality in
the equation and care about is when
there's a supposed hierarchy in the
situation that's another point but when
you when you don't like somebody else
you feel like you're better than I
should say someone else so it's more you
know a feeling of superiority I deserve
this not me
um so that's another reason so private
keyboard is the kind of kid but actually
the fourth thing is expressing yeah that
job that you feel like what's this like
why is this happen it should be me and
that's once again it can link to cover
the fifth thing is fear of failure like
of an objective for it for example that
you're both in business you and a friend
of yours and you're in the same line of
work and you feel like the more this guy
succeeds the more you're gonna fail you
see
the more he loves her the less he loves
me and both things are kind of misplaced
here the sixth thing is name and power
that you want in jail you want status
and you want Power and so you feel like
this guy shouldn't be getting that power
it should be me and the seventh thing is
basically you're narrow-minded and
believe everything good should come to
you especially in this particular
industry why wasn't it me that got this
interview why isn't me that got for
example wasn't called to do this talk
whatever maybe I'm just speaking about
kind of what happens in our industry why
wasn't it me that happens here or why
wasn't it for example in this classroom
setting why was the teacher didn't
choose me or in a sports day event why
didn't the the team choose me for
example so people every one another for
four kinds of reasons that power wealth
Etc but the truth is on these points
religious people shouldn't really have
it now what's the medicine because
obviously religious people would you
know they shouldn't she want money and
power and wealth and things at the end
of the day if you believe in an
afterlife these things are all temporal
and transient that's the first thing the
second thing is what is the medicine now
the first thing is to know and this is
point one of the medicine he says that
you've got to know that this is
injurious to someone in this world and
in here after it hurts you it's only
there is no benefit there's no utility
that comes from being envious this is
the first point
the second thing is that it burns your
heart and mind it's it's kind of like
you know a rash or some kind of itch
yeah it's or an insatiable uh feeling or
unquenchable first it's there is no end
to it
so unless you realistically want there
to be an end for it and try your best to
put an end to it then there's not going
to be an end to it and the third point
is you should feel the knowledge that
you're not actually harming the person
being Envy the fact if the person being
envied has a mutual dislike towards you
you're actually doing something which is
in their favor because you're injuring
yourself and of course when someone does
this it's a waste of energy and you
can't change the decree of God anyway so
it's like smashing your head against a
mountain you're not going to change
anything the fourth thing is that not
only does it benefit the envied person
maybe this Dunya through your worldly
anxiety and so on but will also benefit
the Envy person in the Hereafter if you
stop backbiting the individual and so on
on the day of judgment and so these are
the kind of medicines he also mentions
in terms of actions you should try maybe
you facilitate the good that that person
is doing doing an app because this is a
theme that runs throughout facilities
work is that if you feel a certain way
do the opposite so do an action opposite
of the course praise the envied person
say good things about them or even if
you don't envy them but you feel that
you may Envy them then praise them and
do good for them so that the Envy
doesn't come into your heart and these
are the kinds of practical advices that
he has put forward
one subject which I have been in my own
public life talking about Islam and
things like that deficient in mentioning
as much as I should really
is love
and not least because the religion of
Islam has a major emphasis of Love Of
course Allah
is referred to as a wadut or the loving
one it's one of the names of God
himself and of course Ali and his
Masterpiece he has a whole book of love
which has been translated
I'm just going to talk about some of the
things that he mentions in that book
which I think is very pertinent this
discussion
first of all what is love I think this
is the first question anyone should ask
what is love itself
and really a linguistic definition as
mundane as it is is simply inclination
in Mayland okay which is al-hope which
is love is really an inclination to a
thing
um Ash which is if you like exuberant
love is a higher level even erotic love
or romantic love or whatever you want to
translate it as
it's the kind of love you would or
infatuation in
it's the kind of love you would describe
between romantic partners
a husband and a wife for example
now
to to proceed with this obviously there
are things you can love it's possible to
love humans and non-humans now what
you're talking about here from Muslim
perspective or a human perspective
you can love something which is
non-human
you can be inclined to it so for example
the Hadith the prophet that two things
have been made beloved to me or lovable
to me and he mentions a prieb is one of
them which is perfume
which is something you smell it's Ali
mentions it's not something which you
see with your eye or it's interesting
it's perceptible through the
um the sense of smell so you can even
love something which you can't see or
you can't hear
and which is not human
uh but the question is what do we love
then and what what is the rationale
behind it is it something it doesn't
have a rational does love have a
rationale
um
yes it does have a rationale and really
this is uh the main rationale is about
survival and now this sounds very much
like something you would hear
from an evolutionary psychologist or
something like that but this is
something that al-ghazali does mention
quite frankly in fact he's very explicit
about it
he says that you know we love all things
which fulfilled the objective of
uh basically allowing our existence to
continue
it's a kind of survival mechanism
anything which has the objective
of allowing me to exist or continue
existing is something I will love
which is why people love their family
and their friends
because family and friends you know they
fulfill that objective of allowing you
to continue existing in the case of
Offspring obviously is a different kind
of continuity but still a continuity
nonetheless
and so there is a base survival Instinct
which is connected to love
and in other words or another way you
could say that we love things
that can benefit us
and this sounds very utilitarian but
nevertheless it's true we love those who
can benefit us as well
and everything goes back in a sense to
this kind of benefit
but he does enumerate that there are
different kinds this is not the only
kind of love I know it sounds very
selfish narcissistic if you like
self-love because what is narcissism
egoism if not an amplified sense of
self-love
everyone has that level of survival
egoism in them this is not everyone has
that it's not unnatural it's not even
something to be ashamed of however
there are different kinds of love so he
says you can either the cause of as
we've said of love and he enumerates
them can either be because this thing
allows him to exist continue existing so
obviously things that cause an
individual pain he won't love them
pleasurable things are loved because for
the most part pleasurable things will
bring us closer to a continued existence
the second cause is some kind of a
benevolence that or some good thing is
San that another person bestows upon you
so when people are kind to you and
they've bestow benevolence you start
loving them a little bit why because
we want our continuous existence
basically
and the third cause is loving
something for its own sake now this is a
very interesting and in many ways he
mentions especially vis-a-vis with Allah
which we'll come to now
is the highest form of love in a sense
you love something because of what the
attribute of that thing is
another reason why you might love
something is because it's beautiful
it's beautiful something you love it you
just look at it even though it may not
benefit you directly but you look at it
and you love it like flowers which gives
examples that gives you example of
flowers you look at flower and you you
love it because it's of the beauty that
it has within it you see
and the fifth thing is he mentions this
kind of inner Affinity that someone may
have to someone else because they've
been through different maybe experiences
that they're similar to them or they've
been through
some trauma together and you know we've
seen this kind of thing nowadays they
call trauma bonding and this kind of
thing but the point is that these are
the five main causes of Love Now with
this
Allah makes the case for loving God
and he says the following this is very
very powerful it says therefore if man's
love for himself be necessary
then his love for him through whom first
is coming to be and second his
continuance an essential being with all
his Inward and outward traits his
substance and his accidents occur must
also be necessary
what he's saying here is if you love
yourself
and if you consider loving yourself to
be necessary then that which brought you
about and is continuing
to allow you to exist you should love
the ultimate source of that which is
Allah
there is nothing
and no one not a family member not a
friend
that can be as benevolent to you as
Allah has been
in allowing you to exist and allowing
you to continue to exist
whosoever he continues is besotted by
his fleshly appetite as to lack this
love
neglects his Lord and creator
he possesses no authentic knowledge of
him his gaze is limited to his cravings
and to things of sense
this is the world
of phenomenal reality which he shares
fully with the beasts not the
Transcendent world the ground of which
no one may thread except him who was
close in likeness to the angels He gazes
upon that realm in proportion to his
nearness to Angelic quality
but Falls far short of it in the
measurement of his plunge to the level
of the bestial world
if you don't have this love for God
despite this Assad and his benevolence
that he has bestowed towards you then
the truth of the matter
is that your ignorant of the reality of
God and this is the point here because
it's not just that God is generous he's
not munificent towards you
in a way that human being may be
but he is purely magnificent where this
kind of beautiful benevolence
can be described
as motiveless from
a selfish perspective in other words it
doesn't benefit God
to give you
he's not being strategically generous he
gives you he is benevolent to you and so
this is extremely important
in addition to that we must appreciate
that we've got to describe why do we
consider things that beautiful in the
first place what beautifies things
source what is beautific vision
and when we consider that God is perfect
from all perspectives now we go to the
other reason for why we love things
which is that we love things because of
their perfection because of their beauty
so if you consider the fact that Allah
has perfect qualities
that he's got perfect knowledge perfect
wisdom perfect power that should shake
something within us move something
within us
to loving Allah not just because of what
he gives us but because of who he is and
that's a higher level
that is higher level love and he
mentions these kinds of things for
example his powers Perfection lack of
power is imperfection all Perfection
Splendor Grandeur glory and Mastery are
loved and their perception gives
pleasure
when we look at certain forms
we can distinguish as human beings
between what are the lovely forms what
the beautiful forms
those which are the ugly ones why
because of completeness or lack thereof
round cars round watches round
architectures or very precise
symmetrical
because we love complete things
and God is the most complete of all
so it takes every reason why you should
love anything loving God because it's
perfect he's the most beautiful
he is the most beautiful from that
perspective he is the most beautiful
and he has the perfect qualities which
in live himself makes him most worthy of
love in addition to being most
benevolent to yourself
now this is truly feel
and this is the highest level of worship
by the way when you when you worship God
because you love him
because of who he is not because you
want some something in return it's
transactional with God the highest level
is because you love
Allah
and he deserves that worship because of
how he is and he says the second cause
of a powerful love is extensive
knowledge of God which over Masters the
heart this comes after the heart has
been purified from all worldly
distractions and connections and his
analogous to sowing
as a sowing of of seeds in in the earth
after has been cleared of grass meaning
if you really want to have a pure love
for God then you have to remove the
distractions of the world the reason why
we don't conceive of God in the ways
I've just described is because we're
distracted from the world we need to
clear up like weeds take out the
impurities and distractions from our
lives before we can refill it with the
Majestic and the powerful Allah
and what's connected to love is of
course contentment
and he mentions you know
nextures in addition to love
contentment you're content with with the
love that you have with the Beloved with
Allah with the prophet Muhammad the
Muslims because they're all in the same
direction
and if love is taken away we all know
what that feels like
it's very painful
if you feel like a child of yours is
lost or your mother or your father has
passed away
there's grief
and so this is what you refers to as
longing when you start longing for the
Beloved how too long for Allah
and he talks about his seclusion that
you should want
one of the things to manifest love is to
want to be alone just to speak to Allah
supplication
and these kinds of things and this is
very powerful
indeed
and this actually increases your pain
threshold funny enough and this is
something that he speaks about
um in fact she mentions
very beautiful coach I put on Twitter in
fact he considers the reward for
suffering has no desire to escape from
it when you know you're doing something
for a beloved for the one who is the
most beloved then it's one of the
ultimate motivation and it gives you
power the like of which there is nothing
to substitute that kind of power
and this will give you like a kind of if
we if we internalize these Notions I
think we will transform our lives in a
way which is uh nothing nothing material
can can provide us
the whole religion really of Islam is
based on intentions
that certainly all actions are based on
intention so what is intentions
intentions of what Nia should Loosely
translates into intentions
as well cost they are synonyms as well
for for the word Nia but what is it it's
really like having knowledge and then
acting upon that knowledge it's
interesting that he starts off his book
he's got a book of intentions he thought
of his book talking about the purest
type of intention and something which
can all relate to like is the the
instinctive intentions for example he
gives the example of an individual is
walking in the street or something in a
wild animal a dog tries to attack him
his will to want to run away from that
dog or to avert the danger of that dog
for example or a wild animal of some
sorts his will or his intention to not
be in that particular place at that
particular time will be very pure
instinctive to call that is the purest
kind of intention but there are
sometimes we have more than one
intention by doing something like that
images for example an individual who
fasts yes he may fast a superogatory
fast a supplementary fast let's call it
but he might he may do so not just for
the fact that he wants to gain reward
but he might feel like you know this is
good for my health obviously so if
someone thinks that this will be good
for my health now they're mixing their
attention is that a bad thing
necessarily well it's not the same as
having a pure intention a fully pure
intention and so if you divide it into
different kind of things like for
example in the sinful acts you can never
have good intention for that
in Islam the halam things the whole
prohibit the things you can never have a
good intention for that as for the
mobile hat or the Halal things in Islam
you can have a good intention and you
can transform them into a kind of
worship but you must be sincere and so
doing like for example if I drank
something or ate something because I
know that okay well I've got some
prayers I've got to do so let me let me
drink this so that I can get stronger so
I can do these things now the act of
eating itself is called the acts of
eating and drinking itself will itself
be an act of worship but ironically the
third if you like category of when you
have to have good intentions the most
important but it's where some of the
biggest problems can be which is worship
itself because that's when ostentation
can creep in or the idea of react the
idea of doing something for show yeah
for example if someone prays obviously
praying is meant to be purely for Allah
like if you're praying the five prayers
or fasting all these things
but if you're doing it so other people
can see you now you've added this aspect
over here and this is the the thing that
the prophet Muhammad says the thing he
faced the most of afflicting the ummah
is
it's not so difficult to Res to absolve
yourself on this someone saw that Allah
himself counsels
they have not just they have not been
commanded except that they worship Allah
alone
yeah the idea of having a sincere
intention is something which is is
Central to the religion of Islam and
it's not it's so difficult yeah some
people may think this is so difficult
and a good litmus test for for its uh
practicality would be if you're alone
and you pray and you fast and there's no
one watching you then this is most
likely to be sincere action obviously if
you remove people from the equation then
there's no one there's no object a
third-party object that you can show off
to then that you're most likely
therefore to be absolved over here or
ostentation is something which is the
most amazing really think carefully
about and it as it really is like the
the basis of the religion of Islam
patience is really a Cornerstone of
Islamic practice there are many verses
in the Quran which kind of relate to
this for example
Allah says
that whoever is patient and forgiving
certainly this is the Pinnacle of action
the best kind of action the strongest
type of action and obviously as you guys
know I'm sure you've heard diversity
and that Allah is with those who are
patient
mentions that a Subaru initial Iman that
the sabbah or patience Loosely
translated
which is basically half of all of faith
and there's a beautiful Hadith of the
Prophet Muhammad
where it says
whoever seeks to be patient Allah makes
him more patient so what is this
patience what is the Sabbath that we
refer to Sabbath is not just patience
because patience is an ambiguous term in
reality in reality it's a kind of
resilience that's what patient what is
sober is a kind of resilience and it's
opposite is al-jazza okay jazza is in
the Quran
that the human being is being created in
state of anxiety that when evil touches
him he is
in a panic state so jeza is not just
anxiety as many translated but it's it's
a kind of panicked hopelessness it's
it's more intense than just normal
anxiety and it's certainly not the kind
of anxiety that people refer to in
modern day psychological literature it's
it's more of a panic it's a hopeless
State and so on what patience is Ali
mentions this in his categories is
fortitude against the impulse of say
desire now you can have a desire to do
things or you can have desire to quit
things you can want to quit things in
life and it will be someone or patience
resilience that will stop you from doing
that and there are two kinds of sabot
there's the physical type and there is
the you can call it the psychological
type physical and psychological the
inner time the mental type and really
both have you know their difficulties
depending on what we're talking about
rasala mentions of interesting hierarchy
says that really patience is a
prerequisite it's not if there was a as
a hierarchy of different things patients
wouldn't be at the top of it in fact he
says love is at the top of it patience
would be at the bottom of it and then
after that you have contentment actually
and then above that would be love
because action done because of Love Is
the is the epitome of human expression
in terms of an emotional standpoint
of course for us as Muslims the Sharia
must be the judge of what is correct
patience and what isn't correct for
patients and if you if you think of or
conceptualize everything in life the
hazardi mentioned an interesting point
he says that look it's gonna either be
in line with your desires or it's not
going to be in line with your desires
and in the case of the latter if it's
not in line with your desires that's
when patience is required that's where
you'll find quite frankly any successful
person in the history of the world as we
know it the history of civilization has
never been able to achieve what he or
she has ever achieved without having
patience as a prerequisite about having
resilience as a prerequisite about
having to do things they don't want to
do whether it is because they're bored
whether it's because they're going
through pain whether it is because they
are angry or they are sick or whether
it's because whatever is fill in the
blanks there's never been a successful
human being in history except that they
have fell the discomfort and accepted
that pain and went forward with it and
that is the essence of a sober or
resilience in patience we have all kinds
of you know patients we have all kinds
of things for example
against the mahasi or the Haram things
and if you really think about what Haram
things we're interested in it's usually
things that are in line with our desires
and he gives he brings forth a lot of
these Parables very interesting Parables
which are good and he's got a whole book
actually in the dean talking about the
two desires sexual desires and the
stunner because someone he believes that
has a very like insatiable appetite for
food that individual is likely to put
themselves in danger they're likely not
to get what they want from life so he
would he makes you imagine food as some
kind of a dog that you must starve or at
least discipline and not into not eating
too much otherwise that dog will become
vicious and he says that you've got to
control your hunger and you've got to
control your sexual appetite through
fasting and other means there has to be
a checking mechanism where you're
restricting yourself so that relates to
desires but there's also a Sabor as it
relates to for example doing good deeds
being continuous being persistent in
doing the prayers for example doing the
five pillar of Islam for example all of
these things and there's also and this
is a very high level of supper as well a
sovereign
afflictions happen during your life that
you were able to go through it and
you're not hopeless and you're not
blaming God and he says that someone is
he Compares it to kind of like training
physical physical training for example
he mentions Three Star Wrestling someone
who's training for a Freestyle Wrestling
or for any kind of exercise he says you
need to train Sabbath like a muscle
subhanallah if you are able to train
someone like a muscle life becomes
easier because it's life can become
easier in two ways if you think about it
life can either become easier if there
are no tribulations all life can become
easier if you are able to deal with the
heart and tribulation in a better way
which reminds me of a quotation that
Bruce Lee said which is that I don't
pray to God for an easy life I pray to
God for the ability to do with a
difficult one nowadays even among people
that are not religious the idea of
gratitude journaling for example has
become somewhat of a fact why because
there's been studies that have been done
on it it has shown to improve
physiological and psychological state it
increases your dopamine it balances your
mood all these kinds of things but of
course from an Islamic perspective you
know this has been one of the main
prescription spiritual prescriptions
from day one it's in the Quran it's it's
actually off-prepeated in the Quran I'll
just give you one or two verses to what
you appetite on the issue and then you
can go ahead and you know research this
yourself one I find very powerful in the
Quran the verses
that if you are thankful I will increase
you and if you are ungrateful then My
Punishment is painful Allah and this is
Allah the blessings of Allah with the
Shocker of Allah with the with the
thankfulness of God what are the key
principles here is if you want more
things in
this world and in the next then thank
God for what you already have what's
interesting is that when you start
thanking God for what you already have
it amplifies in your mind what you
thought you didn't have which is a very
powerful thing for example he's got a
whole chapter on this he starts off by
saying that Ashoka really is one of the
Divine attributes as some names of Allah
are congruent with some of the kind of
states that we can be in or attributes
that we can be described with however
obviously takes a completely different
reality but a Shakur or that Allah is
the thankful one is one of the names of
Allah
what is Ashoka tarifan off of a
definitional perspective the word
shocker really means
or admitting confessing to the fact that
you have been given a blessing and then
praising Allah in this case obviously
for it
there are three aspects of shocker and
each of those three are divided so let's
go through them they're very important
to know the first one is knowledge you
see you cannot be a thankful person
unless you admit that you have certain
things and this is where artificial
humility is actually not humility but
it's ironically the opposite of that
some people will be praised with certain
actions and told that they have certain
things in life and they will deny that
I'll masha'allah if you've done really
well you've done for yourself no no it's
not really anything brother you know no
no there is something and it's something
that you should be thankful for but you
cannot be thankful for something you
don't think you even have
so you must confess to yourself that you
have these blessings
and we're going to talk about what kind
of blessings we're talking about so
number one the knowledge of the blessing
everything starts with that you cannot
be thankful it's a prerequisite for a
shocker you cannot be thankful until you
admit that you have gotten a blessing of
some sorts that it's there that exists
that's number one number two the
connection with the person with the
servant you must realize that okay I
possess this it's changed my life in
these ways so that's another knowledge
you need to kind of connect the abstract
blessing that you've been given with the
applicable reality in your own personal
life and then the third thing is the
nature of the bestowah nowadays we hear
a lot of people who are atheists say I'm
grateful that is something people say
you're grateful to whom who is the
object of gratitude
what is the object of gratitude some of
them will even have the audacity to say
mother nature gave me such and such be
the universe
some of them will say the universe as if
the universe now has an intellect and
has mind and has these features sentient
features so if you don't really have an
object of gratitude your gratitude will
never fulfill the objective really it
will always miss the Mark or be off the
mark so these three things are always
mine and obviously ultimately Allah
he is the one who provides all the good
things and in fact all the things all
existence
any thankfulness is to be done is to be
done to Allah but the prophet Muhammad
also told us
whoever does not thank the people does
not thank Allah sometimes Allah uses as
a cause person X or person y or person Z
these individuals sometimes they bestow
something upon you which you also need
to be thankful for so your husband or
your wife or your parents your children
even why not
and it doesn't say
it doesn't say that those who don't
think the Muslims it can even be
disbelievers that have done something
for you sometimes in the west Muslims
for example were living and we have this
very ungrateful attitude to people
teachers of ours doctors of ours who are
not Muslims and this puts people off us
and as a result of the religion of Islam
as well it's not actually in line with
the Islamic ethic at all so he said the
first thing was knowledge the second
thing was the state when you are now
acknowledging the blessings of Allah
then your statement should be a humble
one and why should you be humble and
joyful in fact it's a natural thing for
you to be joyful happy when you're
thinking about all these things that's
why people put memories on their phone
take pictures videos and so on so they
can remember good moments but why not in
these moments thank God for them instead
of going oh that was a good Nostalgia
instead of that just thinking oh you
know this was
had that God blessed me with these gifts
but you should be thankful for three
reasons or joyful in fact for three
reasons one of them is that because of
the thing itself has value whether it's
monetary value or sentimental value or
any other kind of value the thing itself
has value intrinsic value in fact the
second thing is that you know Allah gave
this to you so knowing that Allah gave
you a gift itself should make you joyful
and the third thing is because whatever
has been given to you has utility has
utility and so the fact that you're able
to benefit from the thing is also
something which you should be thankful
for and as a result of all of this the
third thing is we said number one is
knowledge number two is State and number
three is action and the action here is
the actions of the heart which
eventually makes its way to the organ of
the tongue where you start saying
alhamdulillah
and you're thinking about how great God
is that he gave you such a blessing and
that even if you didn't give you such a
blessing he'd still be worthy of Praise
because alhamdul is not just by the way
it's not just a shocker it is Athena as
well which is praise for the intrinsic
essential attributes of perfection that
God has after speaking about all of that
he mentioned some of the blessings and
he said look if you think about it
you've got two kinds of blessings you've
got General blessings and specific
blessings General blessings include
things like air like when was the last
time I or You said you know subhanallah
ah for the oxygen I've been given I need
to put some very interesting stories
that you know a king at the time of I
think it was the habessid maybe that he
was said he was so thirsty and someone
said to him listen I'll give you a cup
of water so long as if you were told
that if you give up your kingdom or have
this cup of water what would it be in
your last dying moments of thirst he
said of course I will take the cup of
water so the wise man said to him then
therefore this cup of water is a bigger
blessing than your entire Kingdom a
bigger blessing every human being on the
face of the Earth has a heartbeat
otherwise he wouldn't live is that not a
moltwin sugar is that not a place where
you can thank Allah
you always find something to thank Allah
whether it is oxygen or the heartbeat
the energy that is used to sustain the
body of the human being whether it's
done through food or glucose drip or
whatever reason there is a baseline
where all living things that are able to
do so can thank Allah for those things
that they have to give him a life and so
these are kind of General blessings and
by the way you'll find that children are
most able because of their innocence to
identify these blessings the general
ones as for us when we get older and
stuff like that we have this entitlement
schema where we start to think well this
person has that why not me why not me
why not me why this person has that why
not me so things which we consider to be
basic necessities we don't even see it
as a reason to thank God yeah I've got
water of course I've got all that I've
got foodier of course and that's why we
need to go to places where the Prophet
Muhammad said and this is one of the
medicines the main medicines for
ingratitude
look at those people who are lower than
you in the Dunya and don't look at those
who are above you and some detail
foreign
people looking at people's cars of
Bugatti and this one and that one and we
think I wish I had yeah later with them
I wish I was given that which cardoon
was given what do you mean are you not
thankful for what you already have
you're probably especially if you're
listening to this in the English
language
you'll probably have more than 95 of the
world's population what's wrong with us
that we can't thank Allah for these
things the reason why in fact mentioned
this for two main reasons we're heedless
Rapha and jeal we're ignorant and we're
heedless because of the age of
Destruction we're entitled and so we
need to remind ourselves of the
blessings of God
and Allah says if if you count the
amount of blessings that he gave you
would not be able to enumerate them
[Music]
and he gave you from all that you asked
for as another verse in the Quran
subhanallah how ungrateful we have been